we expected immigration to be a big part
of tomorrow night's State of the Union
address the president's first we are
less than two weeks away from the next
government shutdown deadline which may
come down to the issue of immigration
chief congressional correspondent Mike
Emanuel has the latest from the Capitol
tonight could even might break good
evening president Trump's immigration
proposals under fire from some
conservatives they are suggesting it
gives too much it's amnesty today many
legal immigration reforms tomorrow it
doesn't have work force verification and
also it's really a invitation to fraud
it's right for fraud because they're
going to allow a lot of adult illegal
immigrants to apply under the daca
program to get amnesty
president Trump rolled out his proposal
after meeting with bipartisan lawmakers
and one key Republican says the
president's blueprint is a strong start
but predict limits on legal immigration
could trip them up the president's
proposal of allowing 1.8 million
dreamers a pathway forward for with
citizenship is a huge step in the right
direction he deserves to have a escrow
account to draw upon to secure the wall
system not just a wall chain migration
and cutting legal immigration in half
those would be very problematic areas
Senate Democratic leader Chuck Schumer
floated providing money for the border
wall but later said he was pulling it
some of his most liberal members are
taking aim at that part of the
president's plan we had the bad part
comes is the idea of a wall which I
thought was a great idea in the 15th
century when China built the Great Wall
not so smart today when we have
technology that is much more effective
and and more cost effective in terms of
protecting the border a bipartisan group
of 48 members in the house called the
problem solvers caucus is out with a
plan of its own it would allow daca
recipients in the US by June 2012 to
become citizens on security would
provide 1.5 9 billion dollars for
infrastructure planning design and
construction and 1.1 to 3 billion for
non barrier infrastructure it would
eliminate the diversity Visa Lottery
however house
leaders are not supporting this proposal
one possibility is a temporary daca
extension along with a temporary
government funding package to give all
more time Brett a busy day tomorrow my
thing